je voudrais qu'on se parle tout de suite
dans smartphone dont on a déjà parlé
l'autre jour ok mais on va voir un
nouveau point qui est super intéressant
c'est toute la partie photo vidéo c'est
le Honor 70 le nouveau bébé de Honor qui
succès de Honor 50 qu'on avait présenté
l'année dernière et c'est au nord 70 il
est cool parce que on va vraiment
l'envie de Nord d'aller vers le plus
haut de gamme on l'a vu avec le Magic 4
pro je vous ai présenté j'ai quelques
bonnes semelles quelques bons mois qui
est tout simplement un excellent
photophone et un excellent smartphone
alors ici c'est pas du tout la même
gamme parce que le Magic 4 pro on est
dans l'ultra premium ici on est dans le
premier on est dans un très beau
smartphone le tarif il est là je vais
tout de suite il coûte le petit je
t'aime bras là genre une crampe 549 €
sur la version 828 et 8 256 599 € autant
vous dire qu'ici il y a moins de 600
balles on a un smartphone qui est cool
mais pour autant est-il bon en photo
vidéo et surtout au nord nous a sorti un
mode pas piqué des hannetons expression
1985 un mode qui est très à part qui est
très différent et sur les sols à l'avoir
c'est assez intéressant on regarde ça
tout de suite
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec au nord au
nord m'a dit tiens mon bon monsieur greu
on voudrait que tu regardes plus en
détail la partie photo vidéo du Honor 70
alors elle a dit ok on va regarder ça de
plus près donc on regarde ça le plus
près deep day on y va en profondeur
alors regardez moi le truc qui
m'intéresse déjà c'est toute la
configuration alors je vous renvoie ma
première vidéo sur le Honor 70 qui est
expliqué un peu le principe de ce
smartphone je vous expliquer tout au
niveau de l'écran au niveau du
processeur au niveau de la batterie tout
ça donc allez jeter un coup d'oeil à ma
vidéo si ce n'est pas déjà fait parce
que là on va pas parler de ces points on
va vraiment faire un gros focus sur la
partie photo vidéo va regarder toutes
les photos que j'ai fait on va aller se
balader un petit peu on va regarder
également les vidéos comme si elles sont
intéressantes quels sont les limites et
puis vous montrer ce fameux mode dans
lequel Honor croit beaucoup et sur
lequel il faut un très gros focus avant
toute chose on regarde la config c'est
juste là vous avez trois capteurs photos
vous avez trouvé ici alors déjà vous
avez vu moi j'aime bien ce design c'est
un peu à part c'est différent ce sont
pas c'est une signature au nord ok vous
avez un grand angle c'est un 54
mégapixels que bref un point 9 c'est la
Sony IMX 800 vous avez également un
ultra grand-angle c'est un 122 degrés
qui fera également office de maquereau à
2,5 cm on est également sur un capteur
de 50 mégapixels ici en ouvrage 2.2 et
puis vous avez un capteur de profondeur
de 2 mégapixels que vous rêve 2.4 bon ok
et à l'avant elle est là elle est
planquée mon petit lapin juste ici
regardez une caméra de selfie de 32
megapixels ça c'est pour le matériel
maintenant on va regarder ce que Honor
arrive à nous sortir au niveau du rendu
photo d'abord et ensuite on regardera la
vidéo je vous emmène au soleil ça
c'était le week-end dernier en Sicile
pour le mariage d'ami regarder un truc
très très cool alors on a une vue
incroyable la lumière donc on va se dire
est-ce que ça biaise un peu le truc ça
pourrait être oui et non pour moi non
parce que regardez la première chose à
venir regarder c'est les nuages est-ce
qu'il y a des choses qui sont cramés on
voit qu'ici on a rien de cramé on a le
détail dans les nuages même là où vous
avez un peu plus de lumière regardez par
exemple ici ça ça me va bien du détail
tout au fond également sur les petits
nuages on voit bien l'arbre on a bien
les petits rochers ici donc toute cette
notion de contre-jour d'un point de vue
algorithmique c'est maîtrisé c'est joli
on du détail ce qu'on peut voir ici
c'est que il y a un petit boost de
saturation c'est pas surprenant on a
l'herbe qui va être un peu verte un peu
plus tonique le bleu qui ressort
davantage mais ça optimise totalement la
qualité des photos donc ça ça va bien je
sois très jolie on passe sur l'ultra
grand-angle alors ultra grand-angle il
est un peu moins bon il est un peu plus
déformant il sera bien si vous voulez
chercher plutôt un bâtiment et que vous
avez pas de recul ça pourra le faire on
voit que pareil même bonne gestion au
niveau des hautes lumières bon ça
fonctionnera ici pas de souci revient
sur notre grand-angle notre capteur
principal regardez le détail dans les
nuages c'est vraiment là-dessus qu'on
voit vraiment le détail au niveau de la
gestion de haute lumière on voit que
tout est bon bien maîtrisé une fois de
plus le fait d'avoir un truc un peu plus
sur saturé très léger ça c'est léger au
niveau de la mer et bien ça donne une
couleur qui est très jolie j'aime bien
aussi la couleur de la plage c'est sympa
ça marche bien l'ultra grand-angle bon
fractaf on voit qu'il y a un peu la
limite sur le côté comme on est sur un
122 degrés vous voyez il va falloir
serrer un tout petit peu parce que bon
forcément là sur le côté ça étire un peu
bon c'est un côté de profondeur qui est
pas dégueu non plus pareil ici alors là
le soleil était au-dessus il a eu un
poil plus de mal sur cette cette partie
là mais globalement ça fonctionne le
reste est très correct l'ultra grand
angle là bon il fera le taf si ce n'est
je vous l'ai dit sur les côtés mais
c'est du point de détail on peut venir
zoomer un petit peu si on le souhaite
pas énormément parce que d'un moment on
viendra dégrader la qualité mais bon si
vous voulez vous pouvez le faire pas
plus pas moins la caméra de selfie elle
est pas mauvaise alors là effectivement
j'ai le soleil en pleine tronche donc
fatalement et bien c'est tout optimisé
le résultat je trouve correct si je me
mets à contre-jour et que je viens
chercher un peu les histoires on voit un
peu les limites du truc c'est-à-dire que
au niveau des hautes lumières ce capteur
32 mégapixels il a un petit peu plus de
mal si bien faire ici c'est il permet de
faire ressortir le visage du sujet mais
au détriment de quoi au détriment des
hautes lumières derrière qui vont être
un petit peu plus bouffées on voit quand
même bien un peu la piscine vous voyez
là c'est pareil là ça pousse un petit
peu au niveau de haute lumière mais bon
faites attention ne vous mettez pas à
contre-jour à contre-jour vous verrez
mais fatalement ça va venir moins bien
exploser reviens sur le capteur
principal de grand-angle je me sens
vraiment bien honnêtement un peu bon on
va éviter trop si ce n'est pas grave
jolies choses là on le voit bien tout de
suite qu'il y a un côté un peu plus sur
saturé au niveau de l'herbe elle est un
peu plus verte que ce qu'elle était en
réalité mais c'est joli donc si vous
aimez le côté un petit peu flatteur en
venant un peu plus saturé vous aurez un
truc qui sera très très bien ici si vous
préférez le truc très naturel c'est
peut-être pas ce qu'il vous faut ça
c'est vraiment à vous de me dire
d'ailleurs dites-le-moi en bas dans les
commentaires l'ultra grand-angle
sensiblement la même chose la
colorimétrie est assez bien maîtrisé en
fait on reste sur quelque chose qui est
très cohérent donc ça c'est pareil parce
que c'est bien bossé du côté de la
marque là je suis venu chercher un peu
le bazar au niveau de la caméra de
selfie parce que je suis dans une zone
qui était plutôt
ombragée avec un beau contre-jour
derrière voyez là il y a un peu plus de
mal un petit plat de nourriture ok
petite tomate mozza histoire de se
mettre l'eau à la bouche en Sicile bon
alors la macro on peut venir la faire
très honnêtement je suis pas convaincu
hein niveau de cette macro si vous
voulez si vous aimez pourquoi pas mais
d'une façon globale la macro j'utilise
pas après pour venir shooter des glaces
et se donner fin on peut venir le faire
ici ça fait le taf vous voyez là c'est
pareil dans une zone d'ombre je vais
filmer quelque chose qui est très
lumineux dehors et bien dans l'ensemble
c'est pas mauvais une fois de plus ce
capteur principal je trouve très joli
regardez là c'est super joli ça vous
fait vraiment de superbes photos d'un
côté comme de l'autre et même avec le
soleil en pleine tronche on a bien tout
ici le détail rien n'est cramé on voit
bien la colline alors après c'est l'algo
bien bossé élément par élément mais pour
vous donner un rendu qui est très très
qualitatif je vous fais un petit
comparatif ça c'est la caméra de selfie
et ça c'est pas la caméra de selfie
alors si vous voulez venir zoomer vous
verrez ici on voit bien le dos du
smartphone dans mes lunettes de soleil
on est exactement au même endroit on
voit juste qu'il y a une petite
inversion qui se fait entre ici et ici
parce que la caméra selfie va venir
retourner on voit qu'avec la caméra
arrière et bien on a une teinte dépôt
qui est beaucoup plus jolie tandis
qu'avec la caméra de selfie on est à
côté qui est un peu plus bleuté on le
voit notamment ici sur le côté vous
voyez c'est un peu plus chaud donc un
rendu qui va être un peu plus chaud si
vous pouvez prendre votre smartphone et
que vous arrivez à vous cadrer comme ça
vous aurez bien meilleur photo avec
votre capteur arrière qu'avec votre
caméra de selfie bon ok voilà c'est du
point de détails mais dans l'ensemble ce
que le rendu est vachement bien la nuit
ça fonctionne elle va pas être aussi
bonne qu'un Magic 4 pro qui fait
d'excellentes photos la nuit mais c'est
correct il a une bonne gestion des
lumières les scènes ressortent plutôt
pas mal bon ça fonctionne ici également
alors si on veut vraiment être chipoteux
pour chipoteuse on voit qu'il vient
maîtriser là les petites lumières mais
qui a un côté qui est pas trop naturel
on est sur un smartphone haut de gamme
milieu de gamme on n'est pas sur du
premium donc on va pas venir chercher le
point de détail comme on l'aura ici sur
un Magic 4 pro pareil photo prise la
nuit on peut venir zoomer un peu si on
là où il faut faire un peu gaffe c'est
que l'algo va chercher un peu à trop
pousser pour exposer un peu mieux la
nuit et on le voit au niveau des ciels
vous voyez c'est pas terrible c'est là
où il y a un peu la limite du truc donc
il faut quand même qu'il y ait des
sources lumineuses sans quoi ça va être
un petit peu trop poussif regardez le
rendu au niveau de la vidéo je trouve
que c'est vraiment correct dès lors que
vous avez beaucoup de lumière ça
fonctionne on a une stabilisation dessus
donc c'est pareil on a un bon rendu la
gestion de haute lumière est pas mal bon
il a un petit peu de mal peut-être ici
la voyez sur quelques petits transats
mais sinon dans l'ensemble c'est pas mal
je trouve ça plutôt bien donc si vous
voulez venir faire des vidéos en plein
jour et bien vous aurez un truc qui sera
assez qualitatif alors on peut venir
zoomer dessus mais je vous recommande
pas de venir zoomer sur la vidéo parce
que ça perdre un petit peu en qualité
mais dans l'ensemble le rendu je trouve
très quali donc si vous voulez venir
faire des vidéos pour vos différents
réseaux sociaux et bien vous avez ce qui
conviendra ici pas de souci et même pour
venir filmer de la nourriture filmer des
glaces pour Instagram Tik Tok et
compagnie regardez là pas mal cette
petite glace puisque je vous en parle
justement d'Instagram Tik Tok et
compagnie il y a un mode qui est super
intéressant c'est le mode solo cut et
symbole sur lequel Honor fait vraiment
un très gros focus je vous montre
comment ça marche en fait vous voyez il
y a plein de petits points qui sur les
gens oui par exemple sélectionne le
monsieur qui parlent hop là ça va le
suivre ensuite je switch sur la dame qui
est à côté je reprends le monsieur à
côté et ça me fait des transitions
naturelles entre les gens alors ce truc
là il y a assez marrant ça dépend
vraiment ce qu'on va en faire mais je
trouve ça assez rigolo sur le principe
on clique sur le monsieur ici on reprend
ici sur la dame et ensuite on reprend le
monsieur là et ça va me générer deux
petits fichiers vous voyez et le truc je
trouve très smooth la reconnaissance
elle est quand même plutôt pas mal alors
bon ici dans la rue c'est peut-être pas
le meilleur plan mais l'idée en tout cas
il est assez marrante comme vous l'avez
vu le mode solo 4 c'est vraiment cool ça
vous permet d'avoir effectivement un
plan large et si je veux venir suivre
une personne en particulier et bien ça
fait quoi donc vous voyez ça me
reconnaît une personne sur lequel j'ai
fait mon focus j'appuie sur une autre on
voit que ça part ça balaie sur le côté
je rappuie sur l'autre ça balai sur
l'autre donc l'idée ça trouve très
maligne pourquoi parce que je vous le
disais dans la première vidéo que j'ai
fait par exemple moi je suis parents je
vais sur un spectacle voir Eliott à
l'école je prends mon smartphone je
filme toute son école toute sa classe
surtout donc toute l'école serait plus
compliqué et je fais un point sur lui ce
qui fait que je vais avoir une vidéo où
je vais voir lui en train de faire son
spectacle pendant qu'il se déplace et
c'est ça ça le suivra automatiquement et
en même temps j'aurai le groupe comme ça
on a les deux en même temps pas besoin
de faire le choix pas besoin de me dire
bah tiens moi je filme que lui puis moi
je filme les autres non j'ai les deux
directement alors la limite un peu du
truc c'est que on pourrait vouloir avoir
de la 4K pour avoir la meilleure qualité
ici vous aurez uniquement du 1080p ce
qui est déjà pas mal pour toute
l'utilisation ça peut être pour les
réseaux sociaux parce que si par exemple
vous allez voir un artiste que vous
adorez que vous voulez venir partager et
bien pareil vous filmez le groupe est un
focus sur le chanteur ou guitariste ou
le bassiste ou le ou la comme vous
voulez il y a pas de souci et bien vous
le faites c'est vachement cool vous
allez voir des danseurs vous adorez des
danseurs dans la rue pourquoi pas par
exemple et bien vous venez faire un
focus sur un qui fait un solo les autres
qui sont à côté vous pouvez ou si par
exemple vous êtes en train de faire des
vidéos sur Tik Tok vous voulez venir les
partager j'en sais rien moi voir un
format plutôt Facebook un peu
rectangulaire pourquoi pas en format
paysage et un portrait directement et
bien vous pouvez le faire ou c'est
peut-être manière là comme ça c'est
vachement bien c'est à vous de libérer
votre créativité et c'est ça qui est
intéressant avec ce smartphone et ce qui
a voulu faire ici au nord c'est à dire
vous permettre de libérer votre
créativité de vous donner un coup de
Suisse pour votre créativité pour autant
ce smartphone n'est pas parfait on est
un petit peu moins de 600 euros je le
dis je le répète on est d'ailleurs allez
549 euros pour la première config en 828
qui rate très bien c'est d'ailleurs
celle là que je vous recommande à un peu
moins de 550 euros vous avez un
smartphone qui sera bon dans plein de
domaines il sera pas exceptionnel en
photo sur l'ultra grand-angle la macro
ne vous servira globalement à pas grand
chose mais par contre votre caméra
principale votre capteur de 54
mégapixels il fait le taf et il le fait
bien donc pour ramener de bons souvenirs
à la maison vous avez de quoi faire vous
pouvez également faire de la vidéo pour
venir faire de la création très
facilement avec les différents modes il
y en a un paquet et ça marche bien donc
pas de mauvaise surprise là-dessus vous
venez également filmer en 4K 30 images
par seconde ça roule vous avez le mode
portrait le mode cliché nocturne
l'ouverture ça c'est un grand grand
classique aujourd'hui sur Android le
mode multi vidéo que je vous avais déjà
montré dans ma première vidéo vous allez
avoir la caméra avant la caméra arrière
broker ça fonctionne mais surtout ce qui
est intéressant et là où ils viennent se
différencier avec ce nouveau mode c'est
le mode solo cut alors le mode solo cut
il est pas révolutionnaire vous allez
pas l'utiliser tout le temps mais si
vous en avez besoin et je vous le dis
notamment pour venir filmer un spectacle
que ce soit avec le spectacle de votre
enfant que ce soit dans la rue un
artiste ou compagnie bien vous pouvez le
faire et c'est un outil en plus qui
vient dans la boîte à outils des
créateurs donc je trouve ça assez
marrant donc ce que j'aime bien est-ce
que je trouve cool aujourd'hui avec
Honor c'est qu'ils viennent vraiment
travailler la qualité de leurs produits
ils proposent des innovations même si
très clairement sur lequel ça va pas le
truc en fait waouh mais ça m'a toujours
manqué non c'est le petit outil en plus
qui est marrant et qui permet de mettre
en avant ce smartphone donc je trouve
assez cool je l'aime bien il est pas
parfait il est suffisamment complet et à
550 euros vous avez un smartphone de
bonne qualité donc à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous êtes chez Honor
est-ce que vous avez un smartphone de
Honor avec tous les services Google
dites-moi tout ça juste en bas dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve
bientôt pour continuer à parler tech de
Honor mais pas que de plein d'autres ça
c'est chouette je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]